foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing the 10 most hated
characters in The Wizarding World now
let me preface this list by saying that
not all of these people are evil in fact
some of them aren't evil at all we must
remember that being evil isn't the only
prerequisite for being hated some of
these characters are just outright
annoying and obnoxious some of them made
it onto the list for evil acts and some
of them made it onto the list for simply
popping their head up but they shouldn't
have I'll also mention that I don't
really dislike any of these characters
they all make the Harry Potter story
more interesting and for that I'm
thankful for their existence what kind
of successful story is full of neutral
characters with neutral opinions doesn't
sound interesting to me I've tried to
balance my own opinions with the
opinions of the internet so hopefully
I've struck a reasonable balance there
my own top 10 list based purely off of
my own opinions might look a little bit
different anyway I'm about to dive in
but before we get started I want to ask
you guys to pause the video and comment
your top 10 or even top 5 most hated
Harry Potter characters down below
number 10 gildora Lockhart order of
Merlin third class honorary member of
the dark force Defense League Hogwarts
defense against the dark arts professor
and five-time winner of which Weekly's
most charming smile award but let's not
talk about his smile he didn't get rid
of the band and Banshee by smiling at
her this is an interesting one and I
only put him at number 10 because the
overwhelming majority of Harry Potter
fans dislike Lockhart however with that
said I actually quite enjoy Lockhart's
character and his portrayal by Kenneth
Branagh in the films is phenomenal he's
just so good at making him hateable
which makes him sort of likable does
that make sense so why do people hate
Lockhart so much well but quite
succinctly people aren't a fan of his
obnoxious and undeserved ego he loves
himself he's a bit of a bigot he's quite
judgmental he's also a fraud that built
his entire career from State making
claim of other people's accomplishments
his whole Persona is just so ungenuine
9. Percy Weasley the Weasleys are
certainly a fan favorite family that is
with the exception of one shall we say
problematic Weasley Percy though the
films didn't do a great job of
portraying it at one point in the story
Percy's relationship with his family
starts to deteriorate Percy like fudge
refused to believe that Voldemort had
returned to power and so he had trouble
coping with his family who were big
Harry and Dumbledore supporters while
it's completely fine to have opinions of
your own Percy really turned his back on
his Loving Family in a big way which is
why fans hated him so much they mainly
quarreled because he sided with the
ministry at a time when the ministry was
more questionable than ever Percy was
raised the same as all of his other
siblings but somehow somewhere something
went wrong fortunately however Percy
does eventually make peace with his
family eight the karos while many of the
people on this list made it on here for
being annoying or untrustworthy the
cairos electo and Amicus mainly made it
on here for being evil the carrots were
dark pure blood Wizards and Death Eaters
who served Lord Voldemort and eventually
taught at Hogwarts during Snape's regime
and said master electo was the Muggle
studies Professor teaching students that
Muggles were no better than animals and
Amicus was the defense against the dark
arts or should I just say dark arts
Professor they're very existence at the
school was extremely unwelcome and the
way they dealt with the student body was
unforgivable but new beaning is brought
to the term unforgivable if we consider
the fact that on the evening of May 1st
1998 Amica spat in the face of the
Beloved Minerva McGonagall 7. mandungus
Fletcher coward Thief fraud these are
just some of the words that come to mind
when I think of mandunga's Fletcher a
member of the Order of the Phoenix
somehow mandungus Fletcher was a half
blood wizard with a rich history of
criminal activity due to his reputation
mandungus was not well liked within the
order but was loyal to its cause due to
door getting him out of trouble in some
way so why do we hate mundungus well for
starters he abandons Moody during the
battle of the seven potters and is
partly responsible for modi's death
what's worse after Sirius Black dies
mandungus shamelessly raids number 12
grimmel Place looting and selling all
the valuables that lay within the
order's headquarters he's just a
sniveling excuse for a person think
Pettigrew light 6. lavender Brown oh boy
where do I start with lavender Brown
mentioned as early as the very first
book the very first student to be sorted
into Gryffindor lavender only really
begins to become relevant later on
however in sixth year lavender begins to
develop feelings for Ron Weasley
Gryffindor House's impressive keeper she
quickly becomes infatuated with Ron and
struts around the school referring to
her new boyfriend with the painfully
annoying nickname 1-1 if that's not
painful enough for you she also bought
him a necklace with the words my
sweetheart her absolutely over-the-top
approach to loving Ron was already
enough to annoy fans but the icing on
the cake was that their relationship
bothered but very well-liked Hermione
Granger anything that annoys and upsets
Hermione probably annoys most fans 5.
Cornelius fudge Cornelius fudge was the
32nd Minister for magic and served from
1990 to 1996 spanning most of Harry's
years at Hogwarts so what's the big deal
why does everyone hate fudge so much
well besides abusing his power to making
rational decisions where he refuses to
even try and see reason he treats a lot
of people really badly he was an
incompetent fool that couldn't have been
a worse representative for The Wizarding
population and if he had taken action
and actually listened to Dumbledore the
imminent threat that was Voldemort could
have been handled much better his
persistent denial of Voldemort's return
eventually cost fudge his job thank
goodness for the dursleys I've grouped
the jerseys together because for most of
the story they're equally as awful by
the end of Harry Potter I had a bit of a
different opinion on each of them but
I'm going to focus on Harry's formative
is with no living parents and the
existence of a sacrifice that meant he
was safe under their roof Harry had no
choice but to live with the dursleys but
despite him being blood related to
petunia they certainly didn't treat
Harry like family he was like their
lowly servant and was punished in
Unthinkable ways including locking him
in a closet putting bars on his window
and even preventing him from accessing
his own mail and as if the treatment
from his parental figures wasn't bad
enough Dudley bullied him too they were
terrible and I don't think it should be
a surprise to anyone that they made it
onto this list 3. Rita Skeeter I know
what you're thinking three who could
possibly be more hated than Rita Skeeter
well we'll get to that in a moment as
far as journalists go British witch Rita
Skeeter is about as conniving as it
comes she was a journalist that would
write defamation pieces full of
misinformation for the daily Prophet her
reputation was awful and no one was safe
from her poison pieces even Albus
Dumbledore who once remarked that
Skeeter was enchantingly nasty the
dangerous poisonous terrible
misinformation that she spread about
people that she did purely to boost her
own reputation certainly makes her one
of the most hated people inside and
outside of the Wizarding World number
two Peter Pettigrew originally a good
guy kind of Peter Pettigrew wasn't
always quite so hated though I'm not
sure he ever really fit in however as he
Grew Older Pettigrew never quite built
his own identity instead just mirroring
those around him this meant that he had
a very low opinion of himself and very
little strength of character sadly the
internal struggle that Pettigrew faced
manifested itself in a few ways the
first he betrayed The Potters resulting
in the deaths of some of his closest
friends next he murdered 12 Mongols with
a powerful blasting curse and
subsequently framed his other close
friend Sirius Black he also signed it
with Voldemort Peter's actions
throughout the Harry Potter story are
truly Sinister and unforgivable and for
this reason he is and always will be one
of the most hated Harry Potter
characters characters 1. Dolores
Umbridge surprise surprise Dolores
Umbridge bet you expected her to be here
didn't you well I think it's safe to say
that Umbridge is unequivocally the most
hated character in Harry Potter she was
ignorant prejudiced bigoted fraudulent
dismissive and very annoying she really
didn't have one redeeming quality her
intense hatred for all people and
creatures that went to Pure Bloods also
made no sense and was highly
hypocritical as umbridge's own mother
was a muggle Ellen kraknall with a
backing from the ministry umbrage made
the lives of Hogwarts staff and students
a living hell imposing all kinds of
ridiculous rules under her tyrannical
regime after being ousted from the
school she actually later becomes even
more hateable as she goes on to serve as
head of the muggleborn registration
commission if you want to know more
about her family history or the life of
Umbridge I'll leave a link in the pinned
comment and that's it for this video
honorable mentions go out to Argus filch
Aunt Muriel Lucius Malfoy Moaning Myrtle
Cormac mclagan James Potter and anyone
else that I may have forgotten until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live